the preparations continue for this
year's wimbledon unaffected by the news
the tournament has been stripped of
ranking points as a result of its ban on
russian and belarusian players
the decision by tennis's governing
bodies is controversial and
unprecedented and many believe it's a
bad one
it's a terrible decision i think
that this will create traction in
between the tour and the grand slams you
know it's a momentous decision from wta
and atp and no i think it's the wrong
one
a statement from wimbledon says we wish
to state our deep disappointment at the
decision taken by the atp wta and itf by
removing ranking points for the
championships we believe the decision to
be disproportionate we are considering
our options
former ukrainian player sergey stakovsky
believes the top russians could have
been more outspoken against the war
while wimbledon simply believe they have
taken those competitors out of the
firing line these russians players in
particular have family back home and i
think that was one thing that wimbledon
were very aware of i think they wanted
to take the decision out of the player's
hands so they wouldn't have to say
anything for players like the reigning
champion novak djokovic and britain's
emma raja kanu their rankings will be
negatively affected as they'll lose the
points they won last year with no chance
of winning them back after wimbledon
when djokovic's points come off i think
he loses the number one spot probably to
medvedev
who is russian of course so
you know isn't that crazy
but it's unlikely to reduce the quality
of the entry list because of what it
means to play here and because the
winner will take home around 2 million
pounds and the first round loses close
to 50 000. wimbledon you know
survived a lot of things you know there
was only grand slam who haven't staged
the event during pandemic and paid out
all the prize money to the players
uh they were the only one who
who
survived the boycott back in i think 80s
or 70s so wimbledon will stay
wimbledon will have a fantastic
you know tournament they will have
amazing crowds and there will be a
champion for the likes of djokovic and
rafa nadal adding to their grand slam
titles is what's important here not the
points even so as wimbledon prepared to
celebrate 100 years of centre court they
couldn't have imagined it'd be in such
controversial circumstances
jackie baltrow sky news wimbledon